russell what's going on brother
russell are you there my man yeah i'm
here
one of the key things about uh answering
the phone is actually picking it up so
sorry about that so what's up man we're
definitely here hey i'm seeking some
advice today
go for them i'm quickly approaching
about 35 years of service
maybe oh thank you congratulations man
yeah thanks i appreciate that it's been
an
awesome experience so i recently bought
a home when we transferred back to
virginia
um the home was about a half million
bucks
and my wife and i have no credit card or
car loans the home is really it and so
we've done pretty well we've got about
400 in mutual funds
uh which we continue to invest in we've
got another
roughly 230 between roth ira and off psp
and continue to contribute to that we've
got about 115
in cash so my question is
is it a smart move knowing that i'm
going into retirement at least from the
military
and to take a large chunk of money say
300 000 out of my mutual funds
to put on the house which would allow me
to pay the house off by
like 20 29.
if you pulled out the three how much do
you owe on the house total today
490 490 okay now all the mutual funds
you just rattled off a lot of them were
roth so are they all
retirement specific mutual funds no no
no the
the 400 of it is just mutual funds oh
it's just a mutual fund okay so no
penalties if you cash that out
there's no retirement penalties there no
yes just tax right yep yep
um yeah i mean russell if i were you
if you if you wanted to take a chunk and
throw it at the house
because your other retirement i mean you
have some other retirement the ones you
you just named my yeah my first year out
of service
uh my retirement will be eighty thousand
take home
okay yes
i i would if i were you um again i would
not take out for those listening i would
not cash out retirement
in order to pay off that yeah no i
wasn't planning on touching that
yeah exactly but the mutual fund i mean
you have 400 in it
yeah you could take a chunk of it and
throw it at the house because a goal
um obviously is to pay off the home
and to be able to you'll be getting that
80 grand um
from your service and you'll you have
these other these other vehicles
for retirement which you can live off of
as well so having a paid for close to
paid for
paid for home in that big time is huge
so russell i'm i'm uh curious
30 years in the service
and now you're think yeah you're
transitioning out to become a civilian
what are you gonna do
that's the million-dollar question i
have some ideas
i have a side hustle i breed snakes uh
so that's well that's what my little
brother does my brother does that too
yep i've been doing it for about 20
years okay what kind of snakes russell
i want to know does it make a lot of
money but it brings in about 20 a year
yeah wow that's a pretty good gig
do you use real live mice or frozen ones
there you go that's a true breeder right
there we could really get off the rails
on this conversation russell
i like you we could we could but yeah so
go ahead go ahead i was gonna say i i
i'm
a hundred percent with rachel i love the
idea of
you having that great military pension
which you've earned every penny of
and having a paid for house or really
close to paid for house
and um man getting this jet set off
whatever the rest of your life's gonna
be
having the greatest reptile sale
online salesman in the country man
russell the snake man i love it